esta calle de mután había sido el lugar
donde históricamente no solamente se han
vendido los libros en Bagdad una ciudad
reconocida históricamente por su amor a
la literatura sino también que es el
lugar donde se encuentran Especialmente
los viernes intelectuales periodistas
académicos y coinciden que después de
estos 20 años de extrema dureza tienen
al menos mayor libertad de expresión que
lo que tenían cuando estaba la dictadura
de Sadam sin embargo temen que con la
llegada de este número de partidos
islámicos que cada vez toman más poder
en el país esta libertad vaya
retrocediendo incluso muchos temen por
lo que pueda pasar en el futuro
son muchos los cambios en el país pero
si usted me pregunta por mi opinión
personal yo deseo que esos cambios
subieran sido hechos por los iraquíes No
desde afuera del país
Esta es una calle que históricamente ha
estado llena Especialmente los viernes
pero nos dicen Quiénes son unos
constantes visitantes incluso quienes
trabajan aquí que nunca antes como los
últimos meses habían visto tantas
personas como consecuencia del
mejoramiento de la seguridad
especialmente
mis expectativas Honestamente Tenía
mucho miedo pero ahora que estoy aquí no
hay nada que temer todos han sido muy
generosos viene con mil dólares y me voy
con 1200 porque nadie quiere que pague
es bonito no es como dicen la gente
piensa que es una ciudad en guerra pero
no lo es
de la seguridad en los últimos años pero
especialmente en los últimos meses el
número de mujeres que se ven en calles
como estas es muchísimo mayor
si teníamos un dictador tirano la gente
no podía tener libertad de expresión
libertad de opinar de leer pero el
problema es que cuando una sociedad
tiene una cultura antigua una
civilización detrás como la nuestra y un
extraño viene ocupa el país y actúa como
un dueño no como visitante siempre va a
fracasar Así fue